[موسيقى]
ام
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الم يكن الذين
بشروا باحلال دور الجيوش بعد الربيع
العربي حالمين
المتعدد الجيوش الى الواجهه بقوه كبرى بعد
ان طالب الكثيرون في بدايه الثورات بانهاء
حكم العسكر الا تبقى المؤسسه العسكريه
ضروره قصوى حتى في بلاد الثورات الم تثبت
الايام ان الديمقراطيه تحتاج الى وقت طويل
جدا كي تترسخ عربيا وبالتالي لابد من جيوش
تحمي الفترات الانتقاليه العصيبه وربما
بعد الانتقاليه اما زال الجيش التركي
يتحكم بالساحه السياسيه رغم تجدر
الديمقراطيه في البلاد اليست ليبي على وشك
الانهيار بعد ثورتها بسبب عدم وجود مؤسسه
عسكريه قويه تحمي البلاد من تبعات الثوره
المتحد الجيوش الى الساحات العربيه رغم
الثوره في سوريا ومصر ولبنان لانها
المؤسسه الوحيده القادره على ضبط الاوضاع
لكن في المقابل الا تجازف الجيوش العربيه
بوحدتها وهيبتها عندما تواجه صعوبات حررت
من الطغيان الم يصبح الجيش السوري على وشك
الانهيار بعد ان اقحم نفسه في ثوره شعبيه
لصالح النظام الا يواجه الجيش المصري
الكثير من المخاطر بما فيها الانقسام بسبب
عودته الفجر الى الساحه السياسيه الم تصبح
الشعوب مستعده لطرد الجيوش من الميدان
السياسي بعدما عاشت فيه فسادا وخرابا ظلما
على مدى عقود ماذا جنا العرب من العسكر
سوى الهزائم الخارجيه والدمار والطغيان في
الداخل اسئله اطرحها على اللواء الدكتور
فايز ويرى وعلى الكاتب والباحث خالد نبدا
النقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس ات اللواء لو
بدات معك في البدايه قبل عام تقريبا مثل
هذا الوقت قدمنا حلقه وسيادته شاركت فيها
حول دور الجيوش العربيه بعد الربيع
العربيه بعد الثورات وكان هناك انطباع في
ذلك الوقت بان الثورات س تحيد الجيوش
ستتيح الجيوش من الساحه السياسيه الى
ثكناتها لتصبح شيئا من الماضي
بعد عام تقريبا ها هي الجيوش تعود بقوه ها
هي الجو ستسيطر على الساحه عادت في مصر
عادت في لبنان انت ترى ماذا يفعل الجيش
السوري هي المؤسسه الوحيده القادره على
البقاء على الساحه في الواقع الجيش لم تعد
لنا لم تخرج اصلا اه عندما تحدثنا قبل عام
كان الحديث عن حول عن مجالات الجيوش
العربيه بعد انتهاء الربيع العربي الربيع
العربي لم ينتهي الثورات لا تزال مستمره
سواء في مصر في سوريا في كافه الاقطار
العربيه يبقى تبقى المؤسسه العسكريه هي
المؤسسه الوحيده ال اكثر انضباطا وال
المؤسسه الوحيده الجامعه للشعب وبالتالي
هي المسؤوله عن امن الوطن اذن يبقى دورها
فاعل في خلال المرحله الانتقاليه ولا
خلافه على هذه ولكن ولكن ولكن الان بعد
انتهاء الربيع العربي وال الثوره تعود
الجيوش ولكن الان اذا تحدثنا عن دور الجيش
المصري والجيش اللبناني والجيش السوري فهي
ادوار مختلفه لنبدا اولا بالجيش السوري
اعتقد ان الجيش السوري هو جيش نظام وليس
جيش الدوله الجيش الذي يقتل اكثر من مائه
الف اسماء موثقه يدمر ستين بالمائه من
سوريا اه مفقودين بعشرات الالاف مدمرين اه
الجيش السوري هو جيش نظام وليس جيش دوله
اذن هو خارج النقاش وخارج المعادله ويكفي
ان راى وزير دفاعه السابق في اثناء عمله
كوزير للدفاع كتب كتابا عن فن الطبخ بقدر
ما كان هو منشغل مع الجيش مع القوه
ولكن الجيش المصري اعتقد بان الوضع يحتاج
الى وقفه تحليليه وفيها نوع من من ال من
ال ال الوقوف الحيادي اولا بعد خمسه
وعشرين يناير اطيح بالرئيس مبارك شكل
المجلس العسكري ثم علق العمل بالدستور
اصدر اعلان دستوريه جرت انتخابات تم تحييد
رموز المجلس العسكري واخراج المشكله
المجلس العسكري وجهه بالفريق السياسي
اعتقد ان تدخل الفريق السياسي في ال في
ثلاث بعد ثلاثين فجر ان في ثلاث في ثلاثه
اشهر كان كان عليه ان يتدخل لان الافق
السياسي اغلق امام المصريين وبالتالي لكن
انا هي ملاحظات على توقيت التدخل واليه
تدخل ومرفقات التدخل من حيث المبدا على
اليه التدخل عندما استلم الفريق السيسي
كان امامه اه جمع ان كبير ان هناك ال ال
اه الاخوان المسلمين بمحاوله التمكين
والاخوان وهناك المعارضه بمحاوله افشال
مشروع الاخوان كان على السياسي من خلال
الثمان شهور الماضيه وليس لو سمحت ان لا
يعطى مهله اربعه وعشرين ساعه واسبوع كان
عليه ان يجمع طرفي المعادله المتضادتين
وال متعارضين في مصر وتحت م نظريه العصا
والجزره ويصل بهم الى قبل ثلاثين وثلاثين
يونيو حزيران يصل به الى وفاق وطني
باختصار شديد يعني الجيش هذه الجيوش
العربيه الى ثكناتها الى بعد انتهاء
الثمرات انتهاء الثوره نعم بعد حينما
تستقر الامور خالد ماذا كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام انه انت انت مع تجيش المجتمعات
العربيه وانت مع ان يبقي الجيش هو الحاكم
الاول والاخير بوجود ثورات وبدون ثورات
قبل الثورات خلال الثوره وبعد الثوره
محمد يعني انا سعيد باللقاء مع الدكتور
الاخرى ومعكم يعني انتم انتهيت الان الان
يعني انتهى الدكتور الى ان لازم الجيش
تكون موجوده يعني موجوده
لكن اذا كان شي شرعي
الدكتور يقول لك لا انا اقول
الحديث
الدكتور فيصل عن الات الجيوش بعد انتهاء
الثورات لا تزال الثوره المصريه تعتبر
حركه ثلاثين مسيرات هي عباره عن تصحيح
لمسار الثوره اذن لا يزال لا يد لا يزال
المخاوف عسير على اي مؤسسه عسكريه الجيش
المصري او غيره ان يلقوا بالمرحله ويقود
السفينه في حال عجز السياسيين
هذا واجب وطني ولكن انا اقول في حال الان
اجراء انتخابات الرئيس على الرئيس المنتخب
اه عدل منصور وضع الدستور واجراء انتخابات
واستقر الامر
هذا تغير الخطاب على المستوى العقليه
العربيه يجب ان يتم حسمه اما ناخذ الجيوش
كلها مع بعضها بموقف واحد
اما نحن مع الوزير في الحياه السياسيه ان
غير موجوده لان جزء مصر عن سوريا عن
الجزائر على جميل يعني ا ناخذ من منطلق ان
تكون موجوده وبقوه في الحياه السياسيه
امان بعده انا مع فكره وجودها ليس هناك
استثناء المصر لانها وصلت الى طريق مسدود
انما لان هناك لان هناك ثوره قامت اصلا
على نظام موجود اسمه النظام حسني مبارك
ولم يكن ولم يكن تاييد الجيش للاخوان
والقوه شرعيه وبالتالي ما تابع غير
الشرعيه تجعل كل هذا اما اما ما تم على
موسى فهو شرعي بدليل يتم على مبارك واما
الذي تم على موسى غير شرعي وبالتالي الذي
تم على ابار غير شرعيه يجب ان لانجاز
الامور
ويجب ان ان ان تكون بوتين في الخطاب
العالم يجب ان جيش الامور في سوريا الجيش
السوري طالب اللي فيه شرعيه وانتخابات
مصر على حقيقه اذا الجيش الجيش العربي على
حق في بالنسبه ل
في كل ما يقوم به لماذا لانه لانه في كل
ازماتنا اوصلنا السياسيون والمدنيين
الكوارث ثم تحملها الجيش دائما السياسيون
المجتمعات العربيه للكوارث وكل التجارب
العربيه التي تمت فيها دعوه الديمقراطيه
تمت من قاده عسكري التامين كما قالت عسكري
التنميه العسكري التعليم المجاني
حتى لما
الديمقراطيه في تجارب سوار الذهب او تمت
من عسكري حتى ال ما فينا نعمل تجربه
الديمقراطيه في الانتخابات بعد الازمه تم
تم العسكر كلها على غيره الامه وليس
المدنيين ولم يكن المدنيين ان الكوارث
وعباره سياسيه اعمار على مجموعات
تحت المجتمعات انتج وهذا لا وصلنا الكوارث
اذا اذا ما يكون السياسي في مصر هو الذي
يقوم به الجيش السوري في سوريا هو لن يكون
بين الجيش الجزائري في الجزائر اللبناني
والجيش اللبناني كله واحد هذا هذا موقف
عسكري يجب ان لا يجزع ولا نقول ان هناك
هناك شرعيه الدوله لما لما وج الجيش
المصري انه هناك خطر على امن الدوله حسب
امره والديمقراطيه الجيش السوري الان يكون
هناك خطر يعني انت بتتكلم الانسان قدم
تتكلم
السوري ومشروعات
يعني يعني انت تعرف ان هناك معركه تحمل
طرف اخر اللي هو طرف شرعيه وانت لا تعترف
المسؤوليه والاخرين
انت تريد ان تفرض علينا جميل جدا دكتور
اولا من ال اجد من العبثيه ان اقارن اه
الجيش المصري بالجيش السوري ومقام بين
الفريق السيسي ب ما يقوم به جمرات الجيش
السوري الفريق سياستنا في للدفاع عنه عنه
ملاحظات كثيره كما ابديت في البدايه على
المنهجيه والاليه التي تطبقها وكنت اتمنى
انه كان اكثر كثافه وذكاء الرحمه رغم
اعترافه
لكن من الظلم ومن الظلم
البواح ان اقارن ما يقام به السياسي بما
يقوم به الاخرون في مناطق اخرى
كل الدول دكتور
ان نفرق بين
امرين الامر الاول هل نحن مع المؤسسه
العسكريه تضامن للسياده الوطنيه
اما ان ال ال ال ال ال ال المؤسسه
العسكريه تقود الحياه السياسيه
صارت الدنيا كلها على النظام الجزائري
الاسلام السلطه
العربيه اي تناقض
نتعامل مع الجنود كلها كل واحده امالا هذا
التسجيل غير مقبول اطلاقا
اولا لا لا يجوز يجوز ان اعمم لان الظروف
الموضوعيه المحيطه بكل الجيش ال مختلفه عن
الاخر الجيش في الامارات العربيه
الموضوعيه مختلفه على الجيش في السودان
فالتعميم غير غير وارد لابد ان تاخذ
الحاله كحالات دراسيه اه محدده مؤثره لكن
ان نعود للنقطه هل نحن مع ان تستلم ال ال
يعني يستلم العسكري السياسه ام الموضوع
الاخر ان يكون لهم دور حيوي في ارساء امن
وسلامه الوطن اذا اردنا ان العسكر يتبوء
دفعه يقود دفه السياسه و سيطره سيطره
السياسه نعم اعيد بعض النقاط يمكن ان
تطرقت لها سابقا الدول التي قاد العسكر
فيها واستولوا على السياسه الامور تقاس
بخواتمها الان ابدا العراق من ثوره عبد
الكريم قاسم في عام في عام الثمانيه
وخمسين اربعطاش تموز اه سوريا من حزب
البعث ثمانيه اذار ثلاث ستين السودان من
ثمن من اول انقلاب لاعب ابراهيم عبور
ثمانيه وخمسين ثمانيه وخمسين الان بالروح
بل مصر من الثلاثه وعشرين بيقول واثنين
وخمسين بالروح ليبيا من الفاتح سبتمبر
بالروح للجزائر اللي قادوا من الصفوف
الخلفيه بالروح الى موريتانيا
نقارن اذا اذا اذا عدنا الى النصف الثاني
من القرن الماضي قسم الدول العربيه
اسرائيل
العربيه
هذه الدول التي العسكر فيها
المكان السياسه المكان السياسيين الى اين
اتت هذه الدول في الخمسينيات من القرن
الماضي والستينات قسم العالم العربي الى
دول الرجعيه والى دول فوريه متقدمه اتهمت
الدول ال ال انا لا ادافع عن اي نظام عربي
كل نظام لديه من السيئات من ايه
ولكن الدول التي كانت تتهم بالرجل يمكن
لها ظروفها الخاصه الان باوضاع شبه مستقره
لكن الدول التي يتم قيادتها من العسكري
خلال ستين عام اين انتهت العراق واين
انتهت سوريا واين انتهت الصومال وانتهت
السودان وايضا انتهت مصر وانتهت ليبيا
انتهت الجزائر وايضا انتهت موريتانيا احد
ولك كمان هذه الدول القاده العسكر الى اين
اوسلو ها ال اخي انا كنت جنرال في الجيش و
افتخر في هذه الوطني واكثر من لك دكتور
ولكن ال ال ال العسكر الجنرال ما دام
يرتدي الزي العسكري
وينقلب مباشره وهو بزيه وعلى ظهر دبابه
وياتي الى الحكم هو غير مؤهل ان يقود ان
يقود الدفئ السياسيه هذا الانسان يمكن ان
يقول ان يكون سياسيا بارعا
عند عندما يترك بدلته العسكريه ينخرط في
العمل السياسي
يعيد بناء ثقافته والان اذا قادر الدوله
سيصبح عنده ميزه على المدنيين بخبرته
العسكريه لكن ان ياتي على ظهرك بابي هذا
انسان لا يستطيع ان يقود البلد ولا يفهم
في السياسه هذا ما اقوله وبالتالي مقارنه
بسيطه واحده وس اذكر اسماء واسف ان اذكر
اسماء وهم اشخاص توفوا
بانتظار ضباط الجيش المصري المشير عبد
الحكيم عامر كان قائدا عاما للجيش المصري
والسعودي بين الشعب الكرام اركان الجيش
عندما قاد عبد المشير اه المشير عبد
الحكيم عامر الجيش المصري ولكنه ولغ في
السياسه والخمسه في السياسه كانت اثار
السبعه وستين واضحه والجيش المصري اشلاء
ملات سيناء وشارون الذي يسارع على المرض
لديه سجن الجرائم حافل ضد الاسرى المصريين
نفس الجيش نفس جيش عندما كان مسؤول عنه
طابت محترف مهني اسم سعد الدين الشاذلي
عبر قناه السويس وحتى مختبر ليس وعمليه
عبور قناه السويس
تدرس في كل معاهد القوات ال القوات
المسلحه في كل دول العالم وفي ارض المعاهد
نفس الجيش عندما قاده ضابط محترف وم متهم
وجندي عبر القناه ونفس الجيش عندما قاده
ضابط مسيس في السياسه فسد هاو افسدته جميل
جدا باختصار شديد السياسه السياسه اخطر
بكثير
الجيش الحر في سوريا
الجيش المصري انت انت
قياده عسكريه
نحن نتكلم على مؤسسه انا اريد الحسم على
هذا النقاش اليوم هل انت مع وجود الجيش ان
ضده اقول الجيش في الحياه السياسيه
انا اريد ان
انا انا لا
لا لانه
هذا الدكتور بالمائه
العالمين او الموقف العالمي الاساسي كان
خطاب هذه الطاوله
بصراحه
الجيش المصري من سنه كان هناك شو كنت
بتعتبر انه اه اشاده اه
الطنطاوي صحيح والان القوميه الصحيح نحدد
هذا خطا
[ضحك]
في جميع الحالات خلينا نعود الى شيء امر
اخر انتم الان تريد ان تميزوا المنطقه
جيشه جيش مثل الحاله السوريه
انت مع تغيير نظام بالقوه اذن انت
الدوله الوطنيه
دكتور التجربه الدوله البريطانيه وطلعت لي
كلها انظمه بدول الفشل ان تحكم العاصمه
صحيح صحيح
الذي
الان في ازمتها الذي يحتمل في تونس
الثلثين استاذ انت تخلط بين دورين مختلفين
انت تخلط بين دور ان تقوم المؤسسه العسكري
[موسيقى]
بالاستيلاء على البعد السياسي
انت تطلب انا اعطيك
اربعطاش تموز الف وتسع مائه وسبعه وخمسين
عبد الكريم قاسم قام بثوره استلم الحكم ثم
جاءت انقلاب عبد السلام عارف ثم تم
التسليم عبد الرحمان عارف
كان انقلاب
كلها الشعب العراقي
هل وجدت على طول هذه المرحله هذا الشعب
العراقي
الحكيم عامر صدام حسين
الان
لانها مقبوله شعبيا
دقيقه واثنين وثمانين بالمائه تاكيد
الكلام اثنين وثمانين بالمائه من الشعب
المصري مع دخول الجيش الى المعتقل
هناك فرق الاساسي
حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رغم
ما
الاسباب التي تقف وراء قرارها لم تصل في
ثلاثين لانه كانت تصنف هو انه انقلاب انه
ثوره صحيح
الان ما جرى في مصر ما جرى في مصر هو الان
ما جرى في مصر يمكن ان يصنف انقلاب عسكري
من وجهه نظر الاخوه يصنف بانه انقلاب
ديمقراطيه انقلاب الانقلاب ديمقراطي اه من
قبل اه الانقاذ يصرف بانه حراك شعبي تمت
تم تبنيه من القوات المسلحه من قبل
المراقبين اذن هناك خلاف على التوصيف لكن
النقطه بيناقش الاستاذ خالد مختلفه كليا
عندما نتحدث عن دور الجيش في معالجه ازمه
هذا امر مسلم به في كل دول العالم لكن ان
يقوم الجيش
بالاستيلاء على السلطه وان يسوس الامه
ويتولى البعد السياسي هذه النقطه المختلفه
فيها
خارج طالبت به الشعوب
هذا الشارع المصري
لو سمحت الان
الرئيس مرسي عندما تم انتخاب واحد وخمسين
فاصل سبعه بالعشره ليس كل من انتخب الرئيس
مرسي كان معجبا ومغرب اوبتيما بالرئيس
مرسي قسم كبير من انتخبوه كانوا كافيين ل
بديله لاحمد شفيق وبالتالي لكن هناك اخطاء
ارتكبها الرئيس مرسي ومكتب الارشاد حاولوا
ان يرثوا مفهوم التمكين واخوانه الدوله
وبالتالي يشق عليهم الناس الان في حال
وجود صراع بين طائفي مجموعتين كبيرتين في
ال في النهايه اه الافق السياسي اسمح
مسدودا لو كنت مكان السياسي للتدخل يجب ان
يتدخل اذا على ذلك دكتور انا الجيوش يجب
ان تبقى وبقوه نريد
تبقى تريد ان تقول انه الذين قالوا لا
لحكم العسكر في بدايه الثورات
لسببين اولا
تدخلوا في فتنه دمويه لا اراك الله ثانيا
انهم
هما معظم السياسي منهم مع احترامي لهم ومع
اداره على الناس لا تشتغل التحكم الذين
يشتغلوا انه مدى السياسه فاذا ما الذي
يحميني هو القوه التي تضحي ما الذي تقدم
مهم في الشارع السياسي اللي ممكن يصير في
اخر لحظه يمشي وقاعد وجه في الميدان اذن
الجيوش فقط في الدول العربيه مش فقط حتميه
هي
منطقه انا اعتقد تجربه لما ابعد جيوش
الشعوب الان في في ليبيا الناس تطالب ان
يكون عندها
النظام السابق
انت تخلط بين امرين
الحقيقه حقيقه
هذه حقيقه ولا انظر ماذا حدث في ليبيا
عندما تم اخراج المؤسسه
العسكريه من المجال الحيوي بشكل عام انا
ما طالبت باخراج المؤسسه العسكريه انا
طالبت بتقديم ادوار المؤسسه العسكريه انا
لما طالب باخراج المؤسسه العسكريه
لماذا اذا كان
نحن نقول حتى حتى في معارك دكتور حتي من
اجل المفاوضات بانه
دكتور حتى في مفاوضات حتى
لو تركنا السياسيين والعسكريين
الان على ارض الواقع ان السياسيين هم
الذين يحبون الكوارث سواء كانوا اخوان او
غير اخوان
الا الذين يحموننا هم الجيوش تحميل على
الميدان انت لما حدث توجه في سوريا تعمل
جيش انا حبيت
السؤال انت تتحدث عن دوله الديمقراطيه
تتبع فيها الاسس الديمقراطيه ام تتحدث عن
دوله انت انت تضع المواصفه لا اتحدث عن
هذه المساله
ارضيه مشتركه للنقاش لانه كل واحد منا
بيناقش فيه مفاهيم مختلفه انا اتحدث في
اطار وانت تتحدث في اطار لا يوجد لغه
مشتركه
تريد ان تجد
في منطقه
السياسي
كل ما اريد من الدكتور ان يكون موقف واضح
الدكتور مع وزير السياسي
انا اقول يجب ان تكون الجيوش خارج السياسي
بكل صراحه ووضوح يجب ان تكون
لو سمحت
تفضل اخي الجيوش لها مهام محدده في كل
دساتير العالم والامه العربيه ليست هي
مختلفه عن دول العالم مهمه الجيش و اذهب
الى كل دساتير العالم من اليابان شرقا حتى
امريكا غربا من
جنوب شمالا جنوبا حتى روسيا شمالي ومهمه
القوات المسلحه ال محدده ومتفق عليها
عالميا هي القوات المسلحه الدفاع عن ارض
وماء وسماء الوطن ضد التهديدات الخارجيه
وان تتدخل لضبط الواقع في حاله التحديات
الداخليه
هذا الدكتور اضفت عنصر جديد
لو سمحت التعريف غير موجود موجود
انا جنرال
وكما قلت لك يتدخل بالتدخل بمرافقه الشرطه
واذا خرجت الامور عن السيطره الشورى تدخل
القوات المسلحه والشريط موجود
الان هل الامه العربيه مختلفه عن كل دول
العالم طبعا يعني
انا
انا ما بعد ان نقول لك دكتور انا اريد
لا اريد
العربيه
سواء الاساءات في العراق او احسن الصغيره
بس نتكلم عن
يا رجل لا يجوز ان لا يجوز ان تسقط الحاله
العراقيه على ال على على على عمان
اي حديث احنا اثنين وعشرين نظام عربي واحد
وعشرين نظام ونص لانه اثنين وعشرين مش
مكتمل لكل دوله خصوصيتها ويكون الجيش
مفاهيمه لا يمكن اسقاط حاله على حاله تؤخذ
الدول العربيه كحالات فراده ويؤخذ على
الجيش فيها كحال منفرده ولكن عندما نتحدث
بالاطار العام انا اقول بما ان رساله
القوات المسلحه في اي دوله حفظ امن الامن
الوطني للدوله
ومؤثره بالدستور ومحدده بقوانين لا يجوز
للجيش ان يلغ بالسياسه ويقود السياسه ولكن
اذا تعرض امن الوطن للخطر فعلى الجيش
خليني اخذ نقطه هوني بس
قربها شويه خالد طيب انت تريد من هذه
الجيوش ان تكون في بؤره الاحداث في بؤره
الاحداث في بؤره المجتمع طيب لماذا لا
ننظر الى الجانب
من هذا الوجود العسكري في بؤره الضوء ما
شيء الان مصر الكثيرون صفقوا للتدخل
العسكري فيما يجري على الساحه السياسيه في
مصر لكن الا يخشى ان يؤدي ذلك في نهايه
المطاف او قد يؤدي او قد لا يؤدي الى
انقسام داخل المؤسسه العسكريه وفي هذه
الحاله نكون ضربت اهم مؤسسه في في في
المنطقه التي انت تدافع عنها انظر ماذا
حدث الجيش السوري عندما تورط في السياسه
لصالح النظام لصالح النظام اين هو الجيش
السوري بالامس اسقطوا له بالامس فقط خلال
شهر واحد اكثر من تسعين دبابه اين هو
الجيش السوري الان الجيش المصري مهدد في
اكثر الجيش اللبناني عندما دخل طرابلس قبل
فتره هذه الجيوش الا تجازف بوحدتها
كيف لا لا تجوز في الطلاق او حديث لانك
انت تقول عن نظام تدافع عن الشرعيه
في مصر هناك انقسام حاد داخل المجتمع هناك
انقسام بين طرفين ما وليكون هذا القسم
الجيش المصري
هذا الجيش الجزائري عشر سنوات
الانتر اه منقسم
السوري الجيش السوري
هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
اين هذا القول في سوريا انت ترى والذين
يقبلوا هذا النظام حيث وافقت والعالم
السلاح
الجريمه كل ما يدعم
استمرار الجيش الحر او النظام السوري
العالم
الروسي والامريكي الاتحاد الاوروبي
تحويلها التوتر اين هذا النظام الشكل
والانشقاقات
بس خلينا ناخذ هذه النقطه دكتور كيف ترد
على هذا الكلام يقول لك يعني البعض البعض
يقول انه انخراط الجيش في العمليه
السياسيه كما نراه الان مثلا سوريا في مصر
اه في سوريا في مصر في لبنان انه هذا يشكل
خطر على المؤسسه العسكريه يقول لك الرجل
هذا لا يشكل لم يحدث في الجزائر لم يحدث
في سوريا الجزائر كيف ترد لو سمحت لي الان
ردود افعال القوات المسلحه تعتمد على
الاجراءات المقابله الان بالنسبه لمصر ما
ما لا ت ان ان ينقسم الجيش المصري اولا
ينقسم اعتقد الجيش المصري يسعى لان يكون
موحد جيش وطني ولكن ال اه ما يترتب على
هذا الوضع هو بناءا على ما سيقوم به
الاخوان ال ان الاخوان لو سمحت الاخوان ما
هي ما هي ما هي الامكانات او الخيارات او
البدائل التي امام الاخوه اعتقد انهم
ثلاثه خيار لا لا لا لا رابع لها الخيار
الاول ان ينجحوا ان من حارب كان وليس ارض
كان وليس اردوغان وهو صامد ولا تصادم اي
عليك ان تتماسك ولا تدخل في صدام وان تعود
نقطه البدايه وتاثيره مع الحياه
الديمقراطيه
واتمنى عليهم ان يذهبوا بهذا المحكمه لو
الخيار الاخر الخيار الاخر ان يستمروا في
الميادين في الميادين في حاله تصعيديه قد
تكون مقالاتها مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات
البديل الثالث ان يختاروا خيار علي بلحاج
في الجزائر ويدخل الى تحت الارض ويبدا في
قتال وتذهب مصر الى الهاويه وهنالك وهو
وجيش مصر مصر الدوله تذهب الى ما فيها
الجيش
مؤكد الان نعود الى الجيش السوري ال الاخ
خالد انا هنا لا هاجم ولا ادافع انا اتحدث
عن الدوله الدوله بمقوماتها بمقوماتها
الخمسه اخي عندما يصبح الجيش جيش نظام
والان نختلف انا وياك على شرعيه النظام
النظام الذي جاء من من رحم الانقلابات
العسكريه هو فاقد للشرعيه بالتالي من
انقلاب ثمانيه اذار حتى بشار الاسد عقليا
فاقدين للشرعيه اصلا هو لما كان عمره
اربعه وثلاثين سنه وانت سوريا وتعلم ذلك
وتم تعديل الدستور في ثلاثه دقائق عندما
جاء قام ابوه بالحركه التصحيحيه التي
سماها ظلما وزورا حركه تصحيحيه وهي حركه
اسلاميه ادخلت سوريا في نفق مظلم
كان بحكم الدستور ممنوع ان يستلم احمد
يستعمل مكان ومن ثم عدل الدستور اذن اخي
نحنا دستورنا في الدول العربيه ودستور
وهذا الدستور لا يحترم الدستور
لو سمحت لو سمحت كمل كلامي انا ما بقه اخي
انت ما نتحدث عن الدوله بارك انها الخمسه
منها نظام الحكم هو احد الاركان واقلها
تهمه اقلها قيمه نظام ال ال ال ال النظام
الحاكم عندما نتحدث عن جغرافيه الدوله هل
تقسم مثل السودان الانظمه الدير
الانقلابيه وعمر البشير قاده السودان الى
الانقسام ذهبت جنوب السودان دوله جنوب
كردفان على الطريق ومهدد البقره العربيه
على الطريق اه دار دارفور على الطريق هذا
الحكم العسكري
النميري كان يتحدث وهو يساري و شيوعي
ويتحدث من
يمثل قلب العروبه النابض وكانت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه تنقل ثلاثه من السودان الى
اسرائيل هذا هو الحكم العسكري كيف ترد على
هذا الكلام الدكتور الحقيقه ما يقوم بها
العسكر ضروره
هذا مرفوض
الدكتور قال انت تقول لي انه لا تخشى على
الجيوش والجيش في الجزائر لم ينهر وفي
سوريا لم ينهار وسيبقى
الدكتور فلماذا المؤسسه الواحده الشعبيه
عندها امتداد وجذور لانها المؤسسه الوحيده
المنظمه لانها المؤسسه الوحيده
المؤسسه الوحيده
يجب ان تنظر الجيش
وغيره
منهما ليستخدم بالسلبي
وليس المشير
انا ذكرت لك الوجه المظلم
نحنا مختلفين حول المؤسسه تبقى
الجيش هذا سؤالك لا يسال
المؤسسات
القانون امريكا والغرب والعرب الدول
العربيه
الدستور هناك
مش من سنتين قبل الشركات هناك الامه كلها
بهذا المستوى
مشكلتنا في هذا العالم انني اريد وضوح
مشكله مشكله مشكله انني اريد اذا انت مع
المؤسسه العسكريه في تقبل بنتائج
كانت ثوابت
السوري الذي يدافع
وشارع ان تقع في بلده
الدوله
المسجد العلمي
قتل مائه الف سوريا
العالم
سوريا
دكتور اذا كانت كل هذا صحيح فاذا ان يعاد
النظر في الصوره العسكريه لانها
دكتور
انا
لا تتحدث عن الشرف العسكري
يعتبر على الكلمه
انا مقدم
على جبين الدكتور لا تتحدث
ان نتحاور بعدم دكتور
ارجع الى موضوع ال السوري يعني
لا لا لا
انا لا اقصد
لانها بخطاب مرفوض
تناقش لا تعرف
اعرف عن هذا الحديث لن اشارك في الحلقه
الله
دكتور انا لا اقصد
اولا لو اعرف ان هذا النقاش
القول الجيوش العربيه تقوم باغتصاب انها
فاضيه يعني ما عندي عمل
يعني هذه الدكتور الحقيقه ولا مش حقيقه
حقيقه
اذا كان بالمعنى الذي تقصده انت يتعلق
من الاعمال لا اقصد هذا على الاطلاق انا
اقصد بالشرف العسكري اذا كان انت تقول
جلوس فاضيه انها تحارب تفرق للاقتصاد
للاسف يبدو لي استاذ خالد انت لا تفهم دور
المؤسسات العسكريه انت معذور انت صحفي مده
في مجال اعلام انت اكثر مني لكن في مجال
البعد الاستراتيجي والعسكري انت لا تفهم
ولا تعرف ما هو واجبات الجيوش
كله عن ها الموضوع الاقتصاد وكذا اخي هذا
الان
هناك تقارير الامم المتحده الاستقاله بان
هناك حالات الاقتصاد بلغت اكثر من سته
الاف وخمسمائه حاله في مدينه خمسه ارتكبت
من قبل النظام السوري
والجيش الدفاع الوطني والشريعه هذا كلام
اه اه الامم المتحده وليس كلامي الان
عندما تحدث حالات اغتصاب وليس الجيش
السوري مباشره مسؤولا عنها ولكنهم مسؤولا
لو سمحت
انا ما انا ما قلت وليس مسؤولا عنها
مباشره ولكنه مسؤولا عن خلق البيئه التي
ادت الى حدوثها
هذا لا يكون جيشا
هذا لا يكون الجيش لم يفقد احترامه الوطني
اخي الخلاف بين
هذا الجيش يحافظ على
هل كان هناك
خالد نقطه مهمه جدا يقول لك لولا الجيش
السوري لا انتهت سوريا لولا الجيش السوري
لبيع سوريا لسداد الاف اه لولا الجيش هذه
القرارات هذا ما يقوله ولا هذا ما يقوله
انا اقول لولا الجيش السوري بقيت سوريا
موحده ولا سقط النظام ولا تجاوزت الوحده
لكن هذا الجيش هو جيش نظام جيش جيش عقائدي
يرغب ان اعطيها حقائق على الفصل السوري
طيب اخي الجيش السوري خمسه وثمانين
بالمائه من مجمل الضباط في الجيش السوري
من الطائفه العلويه
خمسه وتسعين بالمائه من ضباط في الفرقه
الرابعه والحرس الجمهوري من الطائفه
العلويه من الطائفه العلويه وانا اسف انا
اتحدث هذا الكلام وهذا كلام اللواء سليم
ادريس وهذا كلام كلام لا ي المقداد وهذا
كلام كل العارفين وهذا كلام تقارير
موجوده اذا هذا جيش طائفي وليس جيش وطني
هذا جيش للاسف جيش طائفي وليست جيش وطني
وعندما يكون الجيش
وجد اصلا وسلم اصلا لحمايه نظام هذا الجيش
يعتمد معايير
الولاء وليس الكفاءه بحيث البناء التنظيمي
القرار كيلو لا يفرز قيادات في الاعلى ان
القيادات التي يهمها مصالحها الشخصي
والنفاق والولاء وليس الكفاءه واكبر اثبات
ان وزير الدفاع والعماد مصطفى طلاس اثناء
رئاسته لوزاره الدفاع كتب كتاب
الان ما تحدث به يجب ان نفصل بين يا استاذ
خالد
اولا المؤسسه العسكريه هي اهم مؤسسه
موجوده في اي دوله في العالم لكن يجب ان
تؤثر ادوارها في الدستور
المؤسسه العسكري لها لها دور عسكري لحمايه
الامن الوطني ويجب ان تبتعد عن السياسه
هذه النقطه الاخيره
اغتصاب
انا بعرف الحاله السوريه في اغتصاب
الاغتصاب دكتور في ايام الحاله الجزائريه
لا تستطيع ان تسحبها في الجزائر على ما
فيه
الموضوع خلينا نرجع لموضوع
سوريا مش موضوع خلينا نرجع الموضوع
طيب الان انا سالت سؤال قلت لي لا تخشى
على انشقاقات في الجيوش بسبب ال ال
الحاصله الان مع انه كما قال لك الدكتور
في مصر في مصر هناك اكثر من خيار يمكن ان
يقع هنا هو تحدث عن عن الخيار الاركاني و
هو الافضل لكن لا احد يدري اوكي فاذا
الوضع
يعني السفر الغيب في حكم الغيب على كف
عفريت الامر الاخر الشعوب العربيه الان هي
ليست الشعوب بتاع اثنين وخمسين عبد الناصر
وليست شعوب عبد الكريم قاسم في العراق
وليست شعوب حافظ الاسد في الف وتسعمائه
وسبعين هي شعوب عربيه كسر جدار الخوف وما
عاد يفرق معها الجيش ولا كذا مستعده اكبر
ضابط الكلام
الحاله المصريه
السوري شرعيه الاخوان بس خليني خليني
خليني خليني اسالك يا سيد خالد بس شويه
ضمن خطه في زاويه
[تصفيق]
في زاويه
سيتحول هذا القصف الى ورشه
الى واحد خاسر في هذه الحاله
القط الذي تم ادائه وتحول الى واحد خسر او
الذين حولوا القتل الى وحش كاسر هذه
الجيوش التي نزلت الى الشوارع والان تطلب
الشعوب ما زالت بطلب من الشعوب
سوريا
الاستفتاء
الوقت
كيف ترد على هذا الكلام نحن نتحدث عن
نحن في انا
الرد بسيط الاستاذ خالد مفصول عن الواقع
كما الرئيس السوري مفصول على الواقع ال ال
ال الاستاذ خالد يبدو انه لا يتابع الثوره
سوريا ولا يعني اه مشغول جدا وهي تابعه
الاخبار كل اسبوعين يشاهد فقره هو مفصول
حقيقه على الواقع الواقع ولديه خلط في
المفاهيم اسف اخواني عندما تحدث عن مؤسسه
عسكريه نتحدث عن المؤسسه الوطنيه رقم واحد
في كل دوله من دول العالم ولكن لها واجبات
محدده الخ ال ال ال ال ال خلاف بيني وبين
هذه المؤسسه يجب ان تتدخل في اللحظات
الفارقه
لمصلحه الدوله لكن ان تكون جيش ونظام هذه
هي الكارثه
لو سمحت
عندما يكون النظام فاسدا مفسدا
ديكتاتوريا جاء بانقلاب غير شرعي فهو فاقد
للشرعيه وعلى وعندما هناك نقطه مهمه عندما
تكون الجيوش هي موجوده لحمايه
الحاكم
سوريا كما في سوريا هذه الجيوش ان
تاخرها الرسمي
اصلا تفقد منظومه القيم لكن عندما يكون
الجيش وجد لحمايه الدوله هنا تتجلى به
منظومه القيم
استطيع ان تنكر دكتور بالاتجاه الاخر مش
خالد ما اعتبرنا عداءه بدي السلام
الحقيقه عدو الحقيقه هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان
هناك محاوله خبيثه لانها ك الجيوش العربيه
وهي المؤسسه الوحيده في سوريا وفي مصر وفي
لبنان وفي الاردن وفي كل المناطق في
العراق
دكتور خليني اسالك يعني كمان
ادخال الجيش السوري في هذا الاتون اليس
لمصلحه اسرائيل ضد سوريا او ضد الجيش
السوري وضد الشعب السوري بسوريا في مصر
انزال الجيش الى الشارع بهذه الطريقه ال
ايضا ان الاعداء
في لبنان عندما يدخل الجيش اللبناني الى
طرابلس الى صيدا هذه محاولات خبيثه للزج
بالجيوش لانها هي المؤسسه الوحيده التي
نستطيع ان نحترمها في سوريا وفي مصر وفي
كل الدول الثاني هذا هذا امر اه هذا هذا
من البديهيات والمسلمين ولكن من على لو
سمحت من من هو الملا الملاحظ من الملام
اسرائيل اي دوله ايران كاي دوله الحق ان
تدافع عن مصالحها وانا رديت ام
واذا كانت استطاعت اسرائيل ان ان تخلق وضع
تتفتت من خلاله كل ال ال المنظومه العربيه
المحيطه بها هذا هذا هذا هذا من حقها من
وجهه نظر السياسه الدوليه لكن انا الملام
انا الملام اذا اسرائيل نجحت في مشروعه
اذا اسرائيل تهدف الى تدمير الجيش السوري
فهو يظن نفسه في نفس اسرائيل اسرائيل لم
تخلق الظروف يمكن اسرائيل هيئه بعض
الجوانب منها لكن لم تبدا كل احداث سوريا
لايجاد دور يا دكتور على جدار احد المدارس
من ثلاثه الله في درعا الم يكن بامكان
النظام الاسلامي لطلاب مدارس
الم يكن لم يكن بمقدور النظام ان يستوعب
ذلك الحدث ويخلع المحافظ ويرسلهم الى
الجيش
ما لم يعرف السؤال لم يعترف الرئيس السوري
بخطاب ان الثوره سته اشهر لم يرفع
سلميه المعسكر الثوره النظام وكان الجيد
الذي لو سمحت هذا ما يجيب عليها الجيش كان
عباره عن اداه طيعه وركوب اهين للنظام لو
كان الجيش
لو كان الجيش وطني ولا والنظام اراد للجيش
دون ان تتصرف كما تتصرف عمان رشيد
وبالتالي كان جنرالا احنا له العامه لانه
لم يورد الجيش وحافظت الشعب وحفر الثوره
لكن لان الجيش متدرج ولانه جيش ربيبه فرد
ورهيبه حاكم اه لا ينطق عن الهوى
هذا المقال انا هاي النقطه
لو سمحت لي لو سمحت يا خالد انا اطالب بان
الجيوش تكون جيوش للابطال
وليس للحكام الديكتاتوريين الذين سيذهب
الى مزبله التاريخ
راح يكون فيه زوايا روح وهم قياده الجيوش
اللي كانت تحميلها من مفهوم الوطنيه
ومفهوم اللي مش
هذا كل واحد
وانا اقول لك يعني يعني انا ما زلت عن
الفكره السياسيه
حتى لو
وغير السياسي
الان اليس الجيش المصري ال او الشعب
الاخوان
التضارب السياسيه
وهي المؤسسه الوحيده القادره على التدخل
الامور
ويدور العالم
عندما
الجماهير المصريه بي سي ان ينزل لم تنادي
ل انها ترغب حكم العسكر بقدر ما ان الواقع
اصبح معتقل ومصر على حافه الهاويه
البعض يقول غير هذا الكلام
البعض يقول ان هذه الشعوب هي شعوب متذبذبه
ولا تعرف كذا في البدايه تخرج علينا في
الشوارع لا لحكم العسكر يسقط حكم العسكر
وبعد ان تتورط بالمحل وتسقط في الوحل
العسكر بدليل انه مركز ابن خلدون في مصر
استفتاء تبين ان اثنين وثمانين بالمائه من
الشعب المصري مع عوده الجيش الى الس اخي
انا الان لو سمحت لي لو سمحت
عوده الشعب المصري للمطالبه بالسيسي يعني
ان يتولى الحكم بسبب فشل الاخوان وفشل
المعارضه وبالتالي اصبحت مصر على فوهه
بركان
وكان لابد للقوه الاكثر وطنيه والاكثر اه
وحده واجماع ان تعود وتسيطر على الوضع
وبالتالي الشعب كان محق بالاستنجاد
بالسيسي بسبب الاخوان سعوا الى تمكين
الدوله مكان مشروعهم بدون رؤيه سياسيه
اقتصاديه اجتماعيه و دون وجود رئيس
الاستراتيجيه والمعارضه مع ازلام النظام
السابق مع الدوله العميقه
خلينا ننهي الموضوع
في سوريا سوريا روحوا الجماعات التي تقاتل
وقف السلاح من الشعب
الدماء
بس باختصار شديد الان اين تتجه اين ترى
دور الجيوش بعد ان قطع الربيع العربي شوطا
لا باس به على طريق اولا
مختلفين انا اعتقد انه
سيكون اكبر واكثر اتساعا في المستقبل
دكتور اه الدول الدول التي تنجح في الخروج
من اه مخاض الثوره وتصل الى بر الامان
سيعود دور الجيوش الى الدور الطبيعي ضمن
اطار الدستور دور الحامي للوطن
دكتور فيصل
عسكريه ومع الجيش انذاك نتفق
مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبق لنا ان اشكر
ضيفينا اه اللواء الدكتور فايز ويرى
الكاتب والباحث خالد بن ققه
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين ها هو فيصل القاسم يحيكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]